la filière avicole réunionnaise se dote
d'une nouvelle image
ce logo volaille pays permettent aux
consommateurs de reconnaître les
volailles issus des élevages réunionnais
une garantie 100% local que les acteurs
de la filière ont tenu à présenter lors
d'une conférence de presse all eyes peas
et la volaille locale c'est à dire ce qu
on garantit au travers de ce logo c'est
des volailles qui avait une petite
exploitation familiale des eaux de l'île
de la réunion
nourrissons % de manière végétal et
minéral et puis évidemment avec des
savoir faire réunionnais c'est toute une
dynamique qui se met en mouvement et qui
partage la chaîne de valeur d'amont en
aval
puisque vous avez pour faire le poulet
vous avez le poussin à me redonner vous
avez l'aliment qui permet de nourrir ça
vous avez des jeunes qui s'installent
vous avez toute une économie biais est
là qui fait que vient la réunion gagne à
travers ça à ce jour la filière viticole
réunionnaise représente 680 emplois
directs dont 152 éleveurs répartis au
sein de deux coopératives
soucieux de valoriser la production
locale le département signé une
convention de partenariat avec la
filière l'objectif est double augmenter
la part de volaille pays consommer dans
les cantines scolaires et sensibiliser
les collégiens au fonctionnement de la
filière grâce à des échanges avec les
éleveurs selver revenir dans l'ensemble
de nos collèges échanger avec les
collégiens sur leur façon de faire sur
qu'est ce qu'elle est qu'est ce qu'est
vraiment la volaille pays
quelles sont les différentes chaînes de
production mais également nous allons
augmenter de plus de 10 tonnes la
volaille pays dans l'ensemble de nos
collèges donc très important parce que
comme je les dis c'est soutenir la
filière non seulement la filière
volaille mais derrière cela il ya
également la création d'emplois qui
n'est pas négligeable à dans notre
société réunionnaise à l'heure actuelle
à la réunion la consommation de volaille
pays représentent 40% du marché global
la filière locale souhaite donc
développer ses partenariats avec les
réseaux de distribution comme les
grandes et moyennes surfaces les
restaurants les rôtisseurs et les
collectivités pour les collèges
partenaires de cette action les cantines
proposeront par mois 8 repas
de la volaille pays les éleveurs se
rendront dans les établissements afin de
valoriser leur savoir-faire plus tôt
fait d oiseaux de produit le produit
qu'une fée à la réunion comme on les
produit
comment ils passent de nos productions
de notre poulailler à aux assiettes des
élèves et après pour nous c'est bien une
valorisation de produits
le travail que celles vues qui fait de
bien valoriser sa et fait découvrir que
tout ça est pour nous une meilleure
vente aussi ensuite c'est surtout cela
aux yeux